シュタイナー・テオ: えっと、普段このポッドキャストは日本語なので、英語でのイントロは慣れてないんですが、お付き合いください。これはUIT Insideポッドキャストです。UITはLY Corporationのフロントエンド組織で、LYは日本の会社です。主なプロダクトは、日本で一番使われているLINE Messengerと、Yahoo! JAPANという日本版Yahoo検索エンジンです。今日は本当にすごいゲストをお迎えしています。Dan Abramovさんです。Dan、自己紹介をお願いします。
Dan Abramov: こんにちは、ありがとう。Danです。以前はReactの開発に関わっていたので、GitHubで僕のアバターを見たことがあるかもしれません。その後はBlueskyで働いていました。今はVercelのNext.jsチームでパートタイムで働いています。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして今はVercel Japanで働いているんですよね？
Dan Abramov: その予定です。今はまだイギリスにいますが、ビザの書類は提出しました。どうなるかはこれからですが、年末あたりに日本に移住する計画です。
シュタイナー・テオ: それはすごく楽しみですね。うちのオフィスはいつでも歓迎ですよ。
Dan Abramov: ありがとうございます。
シュタイナー・テオ: ちなみに、ビザの手続きは結構時間かかりますよ。僕は日本の永住権を16ヶ月前に申請したんですが…まだです。
Dan Abramov: なるほど、はは。そうなんですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、Danは早く進むといいですね。
Dan Abramov: そうだといいな。
シュタイナー・テオ: まあ、自己紹介してもらいましたが、正直言って紹介は必要ないですよね。Danが出るって同僚に伝えたら、みんなめちゃくちゃ盛り上がってました。
シュタイナー・テオ: 英語圏だけじゃなくて、日本のフロントエンドエンジニアもみんなDanのこと知ってますよ。
Dan Abramov: へえ、そうなんだ。もう自分はちょっと表舞台から消えたと思ってたから。新しい世代もいるし…あまり最近は話してないんですよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: たしかに新しい世代もいますけど、やっぱりDanはレジェンドですよ。
Dan Abramov: そうなんですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 先週の木曜日にミーティングがあって、「Danが来るよ」って言ったら、みんなチャットで絵文字を連打して大盛り上がりでした。ゲストでこんなこと初めてです。
Dan Abramov: それは嬉しいですね。ありがとうございます。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも今日はReactの話じゃないんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: 今日は全然違うテーマ、ATProtoプロトコルについて話します。ATProtoって、そもそも何の略なんですか？
Dan Abramov: ああ、ATProtoは「AT Protocol」の略で、「AT」は一応「Authenticated Transfer」の意味らしいです。正式名称はそうみたいですね。でも本当の理由は、ユーザー名で使う@マークに似てるからだと思います。ATProtoはアイデンティティに関するプロトコルなので、Instagramのハンドルが@〜みたいな感じですが、これは企業固有じゃなくてインターネットプロトコルなんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど。僕たちはBlueskyを使ってるからAT Protocolに結構触れてるけど、日本の多くの開発者はまだTwitterやXにいて、AT Protocolのことを聞いたことがない人も多いと思うんだ。
Dan Abramov: うん。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、そのプロトコルについてざっくり説明してもらえる？どんなものなの？
Dan Abramov: うーん、説明が難しいんだけど、良いプロトコルって基本的に目立たないものなんだよね。ソーシャルアプリを作るための仕組みで、必ずしもソーシャルに限らないけど、そこが一番イメージしやすいかな。
Dan Abramov: これはBlueskyが最初に開発した新しいソーシャルアプリの作り方なんだ。BlueskyってTwitterのクローンみたいなサービスで有名だけど、もともとはTwitterと一緒にやる予定だったんだよ。でもTwitter側が契約を破棄しちゃった。
Dan Abramov: でも彼らが本当に作りたかったのは、汎用的でユニバーサルなインターネットプロトコルなんだ。いろんな説明の仕方を試してきたけど、聞く人によって響き方が違うんだよね。
Dan Abramov: ウェブ開発者向けに言うと、ウェブのためのアイデンティティレイヤーを切り出そうとしてる感じ。今はアプリごとにログインが必要で、ソーシャルアプリだといろんなものを作れるけど、その中に閉じてるよね。
Dan Abramov: 例えばStack Overflowで回答を書いても、その中に閉じ込められてるし、GitHubでコメントしてもGitHubの中だけ。つまり、作ったものはそのサービスの会社が持ってる状態なんだ。
Dan Abramov: で、もしその会社が自分の好みに合わない方向に変わっても、もうたくさんの努力やコンテンツをそのクローズドな空間に投資しちゃってるから、簡単には離れられない。
Dan Abramov: AT Protocol、略してATProtoのアイデアは、それをファイルみたいな形に引き上げることなんだ。
Dan Abramov: だからBlueskyで投稿しても、実際にはBlueskyアプリにデータを入れてるわけじゃない。見た目はTwitterっぽいし、Tangled（ATProto版GitHub）を使えばGitHubっぽいけどね。
Dan Abramov: でも裏側では、クラウド上のどこかにフォルダがあって、いろんなアプリのデータが全部JSONで入ってるようなイメージなんだ。
Dan Abramov: つまり、すべてがJSONとして保存されていて、この新しいウェブのレイヤーはアプリ非依存。特定の会社がコントロールしてるわけじゃなくて、いろんなプロバイダーでホストできるし、自分でホストもできる。しかもコストも安い。
Dan Abramov: アプリ非依存だから、誰でも既存データを使って新しいサービスやアプリを作れるし、既存アプリともすぐに連携できる。
Dan Abramov: 例えばBlueskyの競合を作りたい人がいたら、実際にBlackskyっていうのがあって、モデレーションポリシーも違うけど、Bluesky APIを使わなくてもBlueskyアプリと完全に相互運用できるんだ。
Dan Abramov: これが大きな特徴で、ATProto上のすべてのアプリは共通のAPIを持ってる。アプリ開発者がAPIを用意しなくても、全部このJSONに書き込むだけでいい。
Dan Abramov: つまり、アプリ同士が直接やり取りしなくても、コンテンツを見せ合ったり拡張し合ったりできる共通の仕組み。APIを公開しなくても、プロトコル自体がAPIになってるんだ。
Dan Abramov: 他にも説明の仕方はいろいろあるけど、一番大事なのは、僕たちが作ったものをアプリから解放して、ユーザー自身がコントロールできる独立したレイヤーに載せること。中身はファイルっぽいけど、ユーザー体験は今まで通りのアプリって感じ。
シュタイナー・テオ: しかもこの話、あなたのブログ「Overreacted」の記事『A Social File System』でもすごく分かりやすくまとめてるよね。
Dan Abramov: そうだね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 実は、ここでポッドキャストを終わってもいいかもしれませんね。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、もう少し深掘りしたいですし、このポッドキャストは主にウェブ開発者向けなので、実はちょっとしたサプライズを用意してきました。
シュタイナー・テオ: ATProtoはプロトコルですが、ウェブ開発者ならHTTPプロトコルには馴染みがありますよね。なので、レイヤーごとに積み上げていって、どこが違うのか、ATProtoがHTTPの上で何を提供しているのか、どうやって組み合わさっているのかを見ていきたいと思います。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: これはHTTPの知識チェックみたいに感じるかもしれませんが、すごくシンプルに進めます。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、HTTPのレイヤーゼロは何のためにあるのか？クライアントとサーバー間の通信標準ですよね。すでに少し触れてくれましたが、ATProtoのレイヤーゼロは何でしょう？
Dan Abramov: そうですね。ATProtoはいろんなものの上に成り立っています。HTTP、DNS、JSON、WebSocket、CBORとか、そのあたりが僕の知っている範囲です。
Dan Abramov: 他にもあると思いますが、HTTPやWebSocketがトランスポートで、CBORがエンコーディング、JSON用ですね。それからDNSもいろいろ使われています。
シュタイナー・テオ: つまり、インターネットの仕組み自体を新しく作り直そうとはしていないんですね。
Dan Abramov: その通りです。
シュタイナー・テオ: 既存のインターネットのトランスポートレイヤーの上に構築されている感じですね。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。あと、独自の仕組みもいくつかあります。たとえばLexiconというJSON型定義があります。RDFやJSON-LD、JSON Schemaは使わず、どれも要件に合わなかったので独自に作ったんです。
Dan Abramov: なのでカスタムな部分もありますが、使えるところは既存のプリミティブを再利用しています。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、ドメインをハンドルとして使うのもその一例です。独自のハンドルシステムを作るのではなく、誰がどのユーザー名を持つか決めるために、既存のドメインシステムをそのまま利用しています。
Dan Abramov: そういう設計が多いと思います。
Dan Abramov: それから暗号技術もあります。いわゆる暗号資産やブロックチェーン的なものではなくて、ちょっと似ている要素もあるけど、必要なら後で話しましょう。
Dan Abramov: でも全体的にはウェブに近いです。暗号署名や公開鍵・秘密鍵の暗号技術が使われています。
シュタイナー・テオ: 数学的な意味での暗号ですね。
Dan Abramov: そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: ですね。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: HTTPもATProtoもURIを持っていますよね。HTTPの場合、ウェブの世界ではみんなURLを知っています。ドメインがサーバーに紐づいていて、DNSがそのサーバーへの経路を解決してくれます。
シュタイナー・テオ: でもATProtoの世界では、共通のURIって何なんでしょう？中身はどうなってるんですか？
Dan Abramov: ATProtoでは、すべてのAT URIは...
Dan Abramov: まず、AT URI自体について話しておきたいです。`at://`から始まって、その後に何が続くのか？
Dan Abramov: 最初の疑問は「それは何を指しているのか？」ですね。
Dan Abramov: HTTP URIは曲や画像、HTMLページなどを指しますよね。そのHTMLページにさらにリンクがあるかもしれません。
Dan Abramov: ATProtoでは、すべてのAT URIはrecordを指します。recordは型付きスキーマのJSONデータです。
Dan Abramov: つまり、AT URIは基本的に何らかのJSONを指しているんです。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、Blueskyの投稿もJSONですし、Tangled（GitHubの代替）のスターもJSONです。Blueskyのフォローも「この人をフォローしている」というJSONになっています。
Dan Abramov: つまり、アプリを通じて自分が作るドキュメントやrecordがそれです。
Dan Abramov: これらのrecord同士はリンクすることもできます。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、僕があなたの投稿にコメントした場合、お互いに自分のフォルダやリポジトリがあって、そこに自分のデータが全部入っています。大事なのは、あなたのものはあなたのリポジトリ、僕のものは僕のリポジトリにあるということです。
Dan Abramov: つまり、みんな自分のデータを自分で所有しているんです。
Dan Abramov: もちろん、裏側でホスティングを使っているかもしれません。Blueskyに登録したとき、どこにデータがあるかなんて意識しませんよね。でも実際、僕はホスティングを移したことがあって、後から移行もできるんです。
Dan Abramov: 僕のデータは全部僕のリポジトリに、あなたのデータは全部あなたのリポジトリに入っています。
Dan Abramov: じゃあ、ちゃんと理解できてるかテストしてみますね。
Dan Abramov: もし1万人があなたをフォローした場合、そのフォローのrecordはどこに保存されているでしょう？
Dan Abramov: それはあなたのリポジトリにあるのか、それとも別の場所なんでしょうか？
シュタイナー・テオ: それぞれ1万人のユーザーに分散されている、って感じですよね？
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: みんな自分のフォロー情報を持ってるからです。
Dan Abramov: まさにその通りです。
Dan Abramov: 例えばフォロワーが100万人いても、その人たちが自分でフォロー記録を持ってるだけで、実際は自分のものじゃないんです。
Dan Abramov: 逆に自分が100万人をフォローしたら、それは自分のリポジトリに100万件のレコードができる。自分がフォローを選んだからです。
Dan Abramov: だから、自分のデータは自分のリポジトリ、あなたのデータはあなたのリポジトリにあるって理解できたら、例えば僕があなたの投稿にコメントした場合、それは僕のリポジトリにコメントレコードができて、あなたのリポジトリの投稿にリンクされる形になります。
Dan Abramov: そこでAT URIの出番です。あなたのリポジトリにある何か、つまりJSONデータにリンクする方法が必要なんです。
Dan Abramov: つまり、HTMLページのリンクの代わりに、リンクを持ったJSON同士がつながるウェブができるわけです。
Dan Abramov: そこで別のプロトコルが必要になる理由が出てきます。
Dan Abramov: もしHTTPだけを使っていたら、例えば`hosting-company.com/you/post`みたいなサーバーにあなたのデータがあって、僕のリポジトリからそこにリンクした場合、ホスティング会社を変えたらリンクが切れてしまいます。
Dan Abramov: ドメインシステムは、コンテンツのホスト先をIPアドレスで変えられるけど、結局`hosting-company.com`に依存しているから、ホスティング会社を変えるとリンクが壊れてしまうんです。
Dan Abramov: プロダクトデザインの観点から見ると、これがすべてがうまくいかなかった大きな理由です。
Dan Abramov: 僕たちはデータをアプリや箱の中に入れてしまって、その中に閉じ込められてしまう。なぜなら、その運営側が権力を持っているからです。
Dan Abramov: それで、あなたの質問に戻ると、AT Protocolのリンクには何が入っているのか？
Dan Abramov: これもドメインの権威から始まります。
Dan Abramov: 例えば`at://dabra.ms/...`のようなものを目にするかもしれません。
Dan Abramov: でも重要なのは、最初の部分が「どこでホストされているか」じゃないということです。
Dan Abramov: 物理サーバーでもないし、そのサーバーのドメインでもない。ある意味、僕のユーザー名なんです。
Dan Abramov: だから、追加の解決ステップがあって、「このユーザー名のデータは今どのサーバーにあるのか？」を調べる必要があります。
Dan Abramov: その後、HTTPでデータを取得しにいきます。
Dan Abramov: つまり、ユーザー名を物理的なストレージよりも前に持ってくる一段階の間接化があるってことです。
Dan Abramov: これによって、実際のホスティング先を後から変えてもリンクが切れないんですよ。
Dan Abramov: これがこの仕組みにした大きな理由ですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ僕なりに言い換えると、HTTPの問題はURLを使っていて、そのURLが場所を指していることですよね。でもその場所は変わる可能性があって、一時的なものなんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: でもATProtoは「絶対に変わらないものが必要だ」と言ってる。常に自分のrepoを指し示すリソース識別子が必要なんですね。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
Dan Abramov: ある意味、本当に「人」を最優先にしてるとも言えます。
Dan Abramov: URLだと、authority部分は物理的なホストを指します。
Dan Abramov: AT URIの場合――技術的にURIと呼ぶべきかは議論があるんですが――authority部分はユーザー自身になるんです。
Dan Abramov: だから `bluesky.com/danabra...` じゃなくて、`dabra.ms/...` みたいになるんですよ。
Dan Abramov: この仕組みで、ユーザーが先に来る関係性に逆転してるんです。
Dan Abramov: ひとつ注意したいニュアンスがあります。
Dan Abramov: ユーザー名って話をするとき、それはAT URIを分かりやすく書く方法なんです。
Dan Abramov: でも実はこれは不安定で、ユーザー名は後から変えられるんですよ。
Dan Abramov: URIの完全な形はDIDという、絶対に変わらない恒久的な識別子から始まります。
Dan Abramov: これが、自分のアイデンティティを管理している限り、永遠に不変なものなんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど、DIDの話に戻りたいですね。これすごく重要だと思うし、「ディド」って読むの知らなかったです――ダジャレじゃないですよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: HTTPの話に戻すと、HTTPではドメインがありますよね。でもそのドメインを失うこともあるし、ドメインによって実際のデータの場所を隠せる。でもドメインを失うリスクがあるのが問題です。
シュタイナー・テオ: それを解決するために、AT Protocolは別のレイヤーを追加して「ドメインやサーバーじゃなくて、アイデンティティが重要だ」と言ってるんです。そしてアイデンティティがあれば、それをHTTP上のホスティング先に解決できる。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。ドメインを失う可能性があるからというより、実際に失うこともあるけど、という感じです。
Dan Abramov: 例えばツイートみたいなものだと、自分のドメインに存在するわけじゃなくて、結局Twitter上にあるんだよね。
Dan Abramov: もしこれをHTTPで設計しようとすると、HTTPのURIは `twitter.com` や `twitter-data-storage.com` みたいな感じになる。
Dan Abramov: でも問題は、Twitterから離れて別のアプリを使いたくても、それができないこと。Twitterをやめると全部のリンクが切れちゃう。
Dan Abramov: 昔は自分のサイトを持っていて、インターネットの仕組みに直接つながってた。ホスティングが気に入らなければ変えればいいし、ユーザーは何も気にしなくていい。ちゃんとアクセスできるから。
Dan Abramov: でもFacebookやTwitter、Stack Overflowみたいなソーシャルサービスに移ったことで、インターネットの本来の仕組みから一歩離れてしまった。もう自分でホスティングを変えられないから。
Dan Abramov: Twitterを使ってると、ホスティングを自分で変えることはできない。Twitterはアプリとホスティングが一体化してるんだ。
Dan Abramov: だから、ここでのアイデアは、コンテンツを別の世界に置いて、ホスティングを自由に変えられて、アプリに依存しない仕組みにしようってこと。アプリはそのレイヤーの一つの利用者になるだけ。
Dan Abramov: そういう意味で、RSSとGoogle Readerの関係に近いイメージだと思う。
Dan Abramov: 自分のRSSは自分で管理できるし、ホスティングも自由に移せる。その上で、Google Readerみたいなアプリで好きなRSSを読める。
Dan Abramov: でも、Google Reader自体はその仕組みに影響を与えない。もしGoogle Readerがなくなっても、誰かが新しいRSSクライアントを作れば全部読める。
Dan Abramov: つまり、本質的にはロックインを避けるため。アプリ側がユーザーを囲い込む力をなくすことが目的なんだ。
シュタイナー・テオ: すごく分かりやすい説明ですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、AT Protocolの可能性が分かったところで、仕組みについてもう少し深掘りしたいです。
シュタイナー・テオ: DIDがあって、それが自分のアイデンティティに紐づくって話でしたよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: HTTPの場合は、ドメインがDNSで自分の場所に解決される。
シュタイナー・テオ: DNSルックアップをしてIPアドレスを取得する感じ。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、DIDはどうやって自分に解決されるんですか？
Dan Abramov: そうだね。まずDIDが何かから説明しようか。
Dan Abramov: これはW3Cの標準で、その部分を再利用しようとしてるんだ。
Dan Abramov: DIDは、実際にどうやって解決するかまでは決めていない、いわばメタ標準なんだよ。
Dan Abramov: DIDは、まず`did:`というフォーマットがあって、その後にDIDメソッドというものが続く感じです。
Dan Abramov: このメソッドは3文字だったりもっと長かったりしますが、どのようにして自分のアイデンティティとなるJSONを見つけるかを指定します。
Dan Abramov: その後ろは、このメソッド用の識別子になっています。
Dan Abramov: つまり、DIDは色んなアイデンティティシステムをまとめる共通の仕組みみたいなものですね。
Dan Abramov: ATProtoは、DID標準でサポートされている2つのDIDシステムを選んでいます。これは特定の条件を満たしているからです。
Dan Abramov: その条件の一つは、解決が速いことです。
Dan Abramov: 例えば「ブロックチェーン全体をダウンロードする」とかは論外ですね。
Dan Abramov: 簡単に解決できる仕組みである必要があります。
Dan Abramov: 正確な条件は覚えていませんが、基本的に2つを選んだということです。
Dan Abramov: そのうちの一つは、彼らが作ったものです。
Dan Abramov: ATProtoがサポートしているDIDメソッドは2つあります。
Dan Abramov: 一つは`did:plc`で、最初は「placeholder」の略でした。最初は置き換えるつもりだったけど、「意外と良いじゃん」となってそのまま使うことにしたそうです。
Dan Abramov: 今は「Public Ledger of Credentials」という意味になっています。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど、それは暗号系の台帳っぽいですね。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。その世界観の影響があると思います。
Dan Abramov: でも実際は分散型じゃないんです。
Dan Abramov: ここが中央集権的な部分です。
Dan Abramov: npmのレジストリみたいな感じですね。
Dan Abramov: もう一つのDIDメソッドは`did:web`で、普通のドメイン検索を使います。
Dan Abramov: つまり、この2つの方法で動作するということです。
Dan Abramov: どちらの場合も、最終的にDID documentと呼ばれるJSONデータにたどり着くのが目的です。僕はこれをパスポートみたいなものだと思っています。
Dan Abramov: これは3つの情報を持つJSONです。
Dan Abramov: 1つ目は、あなたのデータが今どこにあるか、つまりHTTPホスティング先です。
Dan Abramov: 2つ目は、あなたのハンドル、つまりドメインのユーザー名です。
Dan Abramov: これはホスティング先と全く違っていてもOKです。
Dan Abramov: 3つ目は、あなたの公開鍵です。
Dan Abramov: つまり、誰かがレコードを検証したいときに、どの公開鍵で検証するかという情報ですね。
Dan Abramov: これが2つの方式です。
Dan Abramov: 違いは、一方がより中央集権的だということです。
Dan Abramov: 法的には、これを独立したスイスの組織として切り離す予定です。
Dan Abramov: 目標は、ルートDNSがICANNによって管理されているように、中立的な組織が運営する形に進化させることです。
Dan Abramov: 中央集権的であること自体がポイントで、そのIDの下に何があるかを決定する権威的な場所なんです。
Dan Abramov: でも、中央集権であることの問題を緩和するための仕組みもいろいろ考えられています。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、完全にオープンソースです。
Dan Abramov: プライベートな状態は一切ありません。
Dan Abramov: 公開データだけで完全にリプレイ可能です。
Dan Abramov: 監査もできます。
Dan Abramov: 監査ログもあります。
Dan Abramov: すべてのトランザクションを確認できます。
Dan Abramov: 監査性がとても高いんです。
Dan Abramov: それが一般的なやり方ですね。
Dan Abramov: Blueskyにサインアップすると、`did:plc`のIDが発行されます。
Dan Abramov: PLCはあなたのDID documentを保持しているものです。
Dan Abramov: でも、中央集権が嫌なら`did:web`もあって、こちらはハッシュじゃなくてドメイン自体がIDになります。
Dan Abramov: `did:plc`だとハッシュが割り当てられます。
Dan Abramov: `did:web`だとドメインがIDになります。
Dan Abramov: でもドメインを失うと、もう自分のIDをコントロールできなくなって、実質的に消滅します。
Dan Abramov: だから、これは本当に分散化を求める人向けの選択肢ですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: つまり、PLC directoryはPLC方式のDIDを検索できる中央集権的な場所なんですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: それに「Public Ledger」って名前から、台帳を誰でも見られる仕組みがあるってことですよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 台帳で何が起きたか確認できて、「public」だからみんなが見られるってことですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: どこかにHTTPリクエストを送れば、自分のID情報を取得できるんですか？
Dan Abramov: そうです。
Dan Abramov: PLC directoryというものがあります。
Dan Abramov: それはウェブサイトです。
Dan Abramov: DIDの解決はこんな感じで簡単にできます。
Dan Abramov: `curl https://plc.directory/`
Dan Abramov: これで自分のJSONが取得できます。
Dan Abramov: つまりAPIが用意されています。
Dan Abramov: 過去バージョンを取得するAPIもありますよ。
Dan Abramov: 各DID documentについて、今どうなっているか、過去にどうだったかも確認できます。
Dan Abramov: それぞれの変更が、前のDID documentの公開鍵で署名されていることも検証できます。
Dan Abramov: つまり、DID documentが改ざんされていないことを独立して検証できるんです。なぜなら署名はユーザーの秘密鍵でされていて、PLC directoryはそれを持っていません。
Dan Abramov: そして、最初のDID documentをハッシュ化したものが、PLC上でのあなたの識別子になります。
Dan Abramov: 最初のバージョンも署名があるので、正しいことを検証できます。
Dan Abramov: それは、最初の署名済みドキュメントのハッシュです。
Dan Abramov: だから、ユーザーごとに、ホスティングや鍵ペア、ユーザー名の変更も含めて、IDの変更履歴全体を再帰的に検証できます。
シュタイナー・テオ: つまり、パスポートに何が起きたかを暗号的に検証できるイベントの連鎖になっていて、最初のエントリがDID自体、つまり識別子そのものなので、抜けがないんですね。
Dan Abramov: そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど。
Dan Abramov: うん。
シュタイナー・テオ: すごいですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: それで、中には3つの要素があるって言ってましたよね。
Dan Abramov: そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: エイリアスがあって、データの保存場所があって…
Dan Abramov: うん。
シュタイナー・テオ: …で、最後の要素は何でしたっけ？
Dan Abramov: 公開鍵です。
シュタイナー・テオ: 公開鍵ですね。なるほど。
シュタイナー・テオ: だから、それが本物かどうかみんなが検証できるんですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、実際にデータはどこに保存されてるの？
シュタイナー・テオ: DID documentには何が入ってるの？
Dan Abramov: それはATProtoアカウントをどう作ったかによるね。
Dan Abramov: 僕たちはウェブの上のこのレイヤーを「アトモスフィア」って呼んでるんだ。
Dan Abramov: アトモスフィアのアカウントを持つのは、Googleアカウントを持つのと似てるけど、ウェブ全体のアカウントって感じ。
Dan Abramov: それがアイデアの一部だと思う。つまり、Googleみたいな特定のプロバイダーに縛られず、みんながウェブアカウントを持つってこと。
Dan Abramov: DID documentをたどると、こう書いてあるんだ...
Dan Abramov: 例えばBlueskyアプリからATProtoに登録すると、ATProtoのホスティングをまだ持ってないから、ホスティングを作ってくれるんだ。
Dan Abramov: Blueskyって実は2つのものがあるんだ。
Dan Abramov: 裏側のBlueskyホスティングと、Blueskyアプリがあって、それぞれ完全に独立してる。
Dan Abramov: 実は僕もホスティングを別のプロバイダーに変えたんだ。
Dan Abramov: 自分でホスティングすることもできるよ。自分でサーバーを立てるのもすごく安い。
Dan Abramov: Bluesky経由で登録すると、`*.host.bsky.network`みたいなものを指すようになるんだ。
Dan Abramov: これは君のJSONをホストして、秘密鍵も持ってて、データを配信できるサーバーだよ。
Dan Abramov: アプリが君の投稿を知りたければ、そのサーバーが投稿や他のアトモスフィアアプリの情報も配信できる。
Dan Abramov: さらに、変更があったときに通知するためのWebSocket接続も提供してる。
Dan Abramov: だからこれ全体がリアルタイムで動くんだ。
Dan Abramov: 単なるプル型じゃないんだよ。
Dan Abramov: アプリは君のホスティングにサブスクライブして、何か変化があればすぐ通知されて、データベースに取り込める。
シュタイナー・テオ: 従来のウェブだと、例えばTwitterのサーバーがそれにあたる感じだよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えばTwitterに投稿したいときは、そのままTwitterのサーバーに送られますよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: でもATProtoだと、ここがPDS、つまりPersonal Data Serverの部分なんですよね。
Dan Abramov: そうそう。はい。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして自分のデータは1つのサーバーにしか存在しません。
シュタイナー・テオ: だから、自分のDID documentとPDSが1対1で紐づいてる感じですね。
Dan Abramov: そう。自分のデータは必ず1つの場所を指しています。
Dan Abramov: まあ、1つのサーバーが複数ユーザーのデータを扱うこともできますよね？
Dan Abramov: スケールはするけど、自分のデータ自体は1ヶ所にしかありません。
Dan Abramov: 少なくとも、正しい情報の元はそこです。
Dan Abramov: もちろんアプリ側でローカルキャッシュやDBを持つこともあるけど、正のソースは自分のPDSです。
シュタイナー・テオ: たぶん僕、あなたと同じPDSを使ってると思います。
シュタイナー・テオ: 僕はドイツ人で、eurosky.socialに移動しました。
Dan Abramov: うん、そうだね。
シュタイナー・テオ: それがPDSだと思います。
Dan Abramov: そうだね。
シュタイナー・テオ: で、マイグレーションも全部やりました。
Dan Abramov: うん。
シュタイナー・テオ: それがさっき話してた面白いポイントだと思います。
シュタイナー・テオ: アイデンティティは1ヶ所に固定されてるから、データの置き場所を変えても全部ついてきます。
シュタイナー・テオ: だから僕もBlueskyアカウントを持ってました。
シュタイナー・テオ: 最初にサインアップしたときは、デフォルトのBluesky PDSが割り当てられました。
シュタイナー・テオ: それから、たくさん投稿したり、いいねしたり、もちろんBlueskyでDan Abramovをフォローしたりしました。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして、ある時点でそれをヨーロッパに移したくなったんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: その移行の裏側で何が起きていたんでしょうか？
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
Dan Abramov: まず最初に起きるのは、あなたのリポジトリ全体、つまりすべてのJSONがコピーされることです。
Dan Abramov: Gitに慣れていれば、別のリモートにGitをプッシュする感じに近いですね。
Dan Abramov: あなたのリポジトリが別の場所にプッシュされるわけです。
Dan Abramov: メディアも移行しないといけません。
Dan Abramov: 今のところ、そこはちょっと不便です。
Dan Abramov: 画像ファイルを全部移行するには、別のツールを使う必要があります。
Dan Abramov: 今後はサーバー間で直接移行できるように改善される予定だと思います。
Dan Abramov: 現状はサーバーからクライアント、そしてまたサーバーへという流れなので、ちょっと変なんです。
Dan Abramov: 理想的には、もっと速くてスムーズなプロセスになるはずです。
Dan Abramov: リポジトリが新しいサーバーに現れたら、最後にPLC directoryに変更を申請します。
Dan Abramov: 「自分のパスポート、つまりDID documentを更新して、今はこのサーバーがホスティング先だ」とリクエストするんです。
Dan Abramov: これが自分のコンテンツが実際に存在するHTTPエンドポイントになります。
Dan Abramov: それが最後のステップです。
Dan Abramov: その変更がPLC directoryからブロードキャストされます。
Dan Abramov: 一般的なモデルとしては、アプリがID情報を5分とか1時間くらいキャッシュする形ですね。
Dan Abramov: 次にDIDが解決されると、「ああ、コンテンツは別の場所にホストされてるんだな」って分かるんだ。
Dan Abramov: でもほとんどのアプリは何もしなくてよくて、AT URIごとにすでにデータをキャッシュしてるからね。
Dan Abramov: AT URI自体は変わってないよ。
Dan Abramov: もし何かを再取得したいときは、新しいサーバーにアクセスすればいいだけ。
Dan Abramov: だからアプリ側としてはほとんど気にしなくてよくて、基本的にデータをキャッシュしてるからね。
シュタイナー・テオ: つまり僕がやったことは……
シュタイナー・テオ: すべてのデータが入ったリポジトリを持ってたんだ。
シュタイナー・テオ: それはGitHub上にあった。
シュタイナー・テオ: それでGitLabにGit pushして、GitHubの古いリポジトリは削除して、パスポートを更新して「今はこっちにデータがあるよ」って伝えたんだ。
Dan Abramov: うん、基本的にはそんな感じで動くよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: で、そのリポジトリにはJSONがたくさん入ってるって言ってたけど、どんな種類のJSONがあるの？
Dan Abramov: 実はそれを調べるのに便利なツールがあるんだ。
Dan Abramov: pds.lsっていうツールだよ。
Dan Abramov: 「PDS」はPersonal Data Serverの略で、「ls」はUnixのファイル一覧コマンドのls、そのまま入力すると、ATProtoのハンドルを入力できるページが出てくる。
Dan Abramov: ドメインにATProtoアカウントを紐付けていれば、そのドメインを入力するだけでリポジトリ全体が見られるよ。
Dan Abramov: コレクションが表示されるんだけど、これはフォルダみたいなものだね。
Dan Abramov: 自分で検索してみると、DIDが解決されて、ホストも解決されて、eurosky.socialって表示されるよ。
Dan Abramov: つまり、実際にどこでホスティングされているかが分かるんだ。
Dan Abramov: で、これらのコレクションはフォルダみたいなものなんだ。
Dan Abramov: タイプごとにグループ化されてるよ。
Dan Abramov: これらは全部、異なる種類のJSONです。
Dan Abramov: アプリごとに固有なんです。
Dan Abramov: Blueskyアプリには独自の型があります。
Dan Abramov: npmxにも独自の型があります。
Dan Abramov: どのアプリ開発者も自分で型を作れます。
Dan Abramov: 誰かが管理しているわけじゃありません。
Dan Abramov: 逆ドメインで並べられているので、自然とユニークなプレフィックスになります。
Dan Abramov: 何かアプリを作るなら、そのアプリのドメインをそこに入れるだけです。
Dan Abramov: いわば名前空間みたいなものですね。
Dan Abramov: npmのスコープ付きパッケージみたいな感じです。
Dan Abramov: それで、どのフォルダに入っても、そのフォルダ内に同じ型のJSONファイルやレコードのリストが見つかります。
Dan Abramov: ただの普通のJSONです。
Dan Abramov: 例えば「いいね」は、どの投稿にいいねしたかを示すJSONオブジェクトです。
Dan Abramov: これらはリンクになります。
Dan Abramov: なので、いいねや特定のJSONをクリックすると、そこに特定の…
Dan Abramov: 例えば、これは特定の投稿へのいいねです。そのリンクをたどると、実際の投稿がある別の人のリポジトリに行くかもしれません。
シュタイナー・テオ: このポッドキャストを聴いている人向けに説明すると、今pds.lsにアクセスして、自分のエイリアス、つまり自分のドメインyoshana.deを入力して、DID lookupをやってみました。
シュタイナー・テオ: これって、そう呼ぶんですか？
Dan Abramov: そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: PLC lookupですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして、僕のPDS、今回はeurosky.socialを見つけてくれました。
シュタイナー・テオ: その下にはたくさんのレコードが…いや、コレクションが並んでました。
シュタイナー・テオ: コレクションは全部、ある種のタイプでまとめられてます。そのタイプはリバースドメインの識別子ですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えばBlueskyの「いいね」だと、`app.bsky.feed.like`になります。
シュタイナー・テオ: それをクリックすると、Blueskyで自分が付けた全ての「いいね」が見れます。
シュタイナー・テオ: さらに深くクリックすると、実際のJSONが表示されます。
シュタイナー・テオ: ここにはタイムスタンプ、つまり`createdAt`があって、subjectもあります。これは多分、僕が「いいね」した対象ですね。
Dan Abramov: それが投稿です。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、なんでURIとCIDが両方あるんですか？
Dan Abramov: うん、それが君が「いいね」した投稿だよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: URIはさっき話したやつですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: これで他の人のDID documentにたどり着いて、そこからPDS、さらにコレクション、そしてその中のエントリー、つまり投稿まで取得できます。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、このCIDって何ですか？
Dan Abramov: そう、ATProtoには2種類のリンクがあります。
Dan Abramov: ひとつはウィークリンク、たぶんrefって呼ばれてるやつで、普通のAT URIです。
Dan Abramov: もうひとつはストロングリンクで、これはURIとCIDのセットです。
Dan Abramov: CIDはリンク先レコードのハッシュですね。
Dan Abramov: 一部のリンクでは、アプリが「関連してるものが同じものかどうか」を判定できるようにしたい、という考え方です。
Dan Abramov: 例えば「いいね」の場合、投稿が編集されたら、それでも「いいね」としてカウントされるのか？みたいな。
Dan Abramov: たぶんBlueskyアプリは…どうだろう。編集は反映されてない気がする。よく分からないけど、たぶん反映されてないかも。
Dan Abramov: これは編集を無視するというアプリ側の選択、もしくはプロダクトの判断ですね。
Dan Abramov: でももし編集が許可されたら、「今あるバージョンにいいねしたのか、それともいいねした後に内容が変わったのか」を判別できるようになります。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど。例えば「タブの方がスペースよりいい」って投稿にいいねしたとして、その後で投稿者が「スペースの方がタブよりいい」に編集した場合、このレコードを見れば「いや、ハッシュが変わってるから、いいねした時は別の内容だった」って証明できるんですね。
Dan Abramov: そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: それで、このJSONの`$type`フィールドは何ですか？
Dan Abramov: これは、そのレコードが属しているcollectionの名前です。
Dan Abramov: これは常に入っているという決まりになっています。
Dan Abramov: だからURIを知らなくても、レコードだけでどんな種類か分かるようになっています。
Dan Abramov: ざっくり言うと、フォルダ名みたいなものですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、いいねと投稿ではデータ構造が全然違うんですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: Blueskyはどうやってそれぞれのレコードをパースしてるんですか？
Dan Abramov: いい質問ですね。
Dan Abramov: Lexiconというものがあって、型定義みたいな役割をしています。
Dan Abramov: 僕は本当にLexiconだと思ってます。
Dan Abramov: 例えばBlueskyのいいね、Blueskyの投稿、Tangledのrepo、npmxのフォローなど、それぞれにJSONで書かれたスキーマが紐づいています。
Dan Abramov: 面白いのは、それを公開する必要はないってことです。
Dan Abramov: アプリにとっては便利で、実際のパースコードやバリデーション、Zodバリデーションを自動生成できるので、どの言語でも型付きで安全に読み込めます。
Dan Abramov: JavaScript、Swift、Goなどいろいろ対応しています。
Dan Abramov: Lexiconからコード生成するライブラリもあります。
Dan Abramov: でも、Lexicon自体も公開できて、面白いのは公開方法もレコードとして扱うことなんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: うん、もちろん。
Dan Abramov: つまり、型定義を含んだレコードを公開できるんです。
Dan Abramov: 実際、pds.lsでは型が公開されていれば、それをリンクとしてクリックするとレコードが表示されます。
Dan Abramov: さっき見せてくれた画面で、likeレコードに`$type: app.bsky.feed.like`って書いてあったと思うんですが、それを押すと、その型のスキーマを持つレコードを探すためのLexicon解決メカニズムが動きます。
Dan Abramov: そしてpds.lsはそれをドキュメントみたいにきれいに表示してくれます。
シュタイナー・テオ: それ、めっちゃいいですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: こうやって任意のデータを保存できるんですね。データ構造を定義する方法があって、各アプリが自分で定義できるから。
Dan Abramov: そうです。
Dan Abramov: でも、もっと面白いこともあります。
Dan Abramov: まず開発者として、自分の好きなフォーマットを選べるのが出発点ですね。
Dan Abramov: でも既存のフォーマットを再利用することもできます。
Dan Abramov: 例えばBluesky用のプラグインを作るなら、Blueskyのfollowsフォーマットをそのまま使うこともできます。
Dan Abramov: あるいは、Community Notesみたいな注釈機能を作る場合も同じです。
Dan Abramov: その場合はBlueskyがそれをやるのも自然かもしれません。
Dan Abramov: でも、注釈系の何かを作るとして、その対象をBlueskyの投稿やTangledのリポジトリ、他にも何でもリンクできるようにできます。
Dan Abramov: そういう意味で、他のアプリのフォーマットも使えるんです。
Dan Abramov: リンクするだけじゃなくて、自分のフォーマットとしてそのまま使うこともできます。
Dan Abramov: ファイルフォーマットと同じ感覚ですね。
Dan Abramov: 多くのアプリが同じフォーマットを使っています。
Dan Abramov: 実は前例もあります。
Dan Abramov: ATProto上には3つのブログプラットフォームがあります。
Dan Abramov: ひとつはLeaflet、もうひとつはOffprint、そしてpckt.blogというものもあります。
Dan Abramov: ある時点で、より相互運用性を高めるために1つのLexiconで協力し始めました。たとえば、あるサービスの購読が他でも表示されるように、という感じです。
Dan Abramov: 彼らは公開やフォローのフォーマットに合意しました。
Dan Abramov: これが「standard.site」と呼ばれています。
Dan Abramov: これはさらに大きなものになりました。ある意味、ATProto上のRSSみたいな存在です。
Dan Abramov: 面白いのは、今では自分のブログがこれらのプラットフォーム上になくてもstandard.siteを採用できて、投稿や公開、ブランドカラーなどを記述したレコードを作れることです。
Dan Abramov: そしてBlueskyアプリでstandard.siteの投稿リンクは、あなたのサイトのブランドカラーが使われた特別なボックスで表示されます。
Dan Abramov: これは、3つの異なるブログプラットフォームがLexiconを共有し、BlueskyアプリがそのLexiconを読み取って情報を活用する例です。
Dan Abramov: そういう意味で、これはもっとダイナミックなエコシステムで、いくつかのものが標準化されつつも、完全にコミュニティ主導です。
シュタイナー・テオ: これはちょっとすごいですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: まるで自分でアプリを作って、最初はユーザーが自分のアプリからInstagramに投稿できるようにした感じですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: ユーザーがInstagramに写真を投稿できるし、投稿した写真も全部表示できる、みたいな。
シュタイナー・テオ: うん、ここでなんとなく腑に落ちました。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。あと、いろんな種類のものをインデックスできるのもポイントです。
Dan Abramov: もちろん、Blueskyの全投稿をインデックスするのは量的に無理があるのでコストがかかります。
Dan Abramov: でも、ユーザーに関連する何かだけをインデックスすることもできます。
Dan Abramov: そうすると、こういうマッシュアップもできるわけです。
Dan Abramov: もうひとつ面白い例があるんだ。
Dan Abramov: それで、Lexiconの話なんだけど——Last.fmって知ってる？音楽の再生履歴を記録するやつ。
シュタイナー・テオ: うん、聞いたことあるよ。
Dan Abramov: だよね。
Dan Abramov: それで「Teal FM play」っていうLexiconがあるんだ。
Dan Abramov: Teal FMは音楽の再生履歴を記録するサービスになる予定だったんだけど、まだリリースされてないみたい。ずっと開発中で、週末だけ作業してるらしい。
Dan Abramov: だから、実際のWebサイトもアプリもまだ公開されてないんだよね。
Dan Abramov: でも、Lexicon自体はもう存在してるから問題ないんだ。
Dan Abramov: アプリがなくても、今聴いてる曲を投稿できるツールはもう作られてる。
Dan Abramov: つまり、このLexiconのrecordを書き込んでるだけなんだよ。
Dan Abramov: それで、Teal FM自体は存在しないのに、再生履歴を表示するサードパーティ製アプリもすでに作られてる。
Dan Abramov: ちょっと面白いよね。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、Teal FM上でよく聴かれてるアーティストの集計とかも表示できる。
Dan Abramov: でも、やっぱりTeal FM自体は存在しないんだよ。
Dan Abramov: 僕のイメージだと、もし世界中のJSONがあったら、プロダクトをまたいでjoinできるよねって感じ。
Dan Abramov: 例えば、Blueskyで自分がフォローしてる人たちが最近聴いてる曲のランキングとかもできる。
Dan Abramov: あるいは、友達の間で今話題のリポジトリは何か、とかも調べられる。
Dan Abramov: いろんなアプリのデータを組み合わせて、クロスジョインもできるんだ。
Dan Abramov: それって、まさにWebっぽいよね。
Dan Abramov: Webの発想をそのままWebデータベースにした感じ。
Dan Abramov: わからないですね。
Dan Abramov: アプリ同士の境界を壊したり曖昧にしたりして、データのウェブがあって、アプリはそのデータを見るレンズみたいな存在になる、そんな感じですね。
Dan Abramov: そしてこのレンズは誰でも新しく作れるんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: プロダクトをまたいでレコードを投稿するって最初はちょっとクレイジーに聞こえるけど、AT Protocol、つまりAuthenticated Transfer Protocolだから、自分のリポに投稿されたものは全部認証されてる。だからアプリ間で投稿しても安全ってことですよね？
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
Dan Abramov: 仕組みとしては、アプリはAT Protocolを通じて常に確認できるので、そのコンテンツが本当にあなたのものだと確信できるんです。
Dan Abramov: アプリはあなたのホスティングにアクセスして、ホスティングがそのデータを返してくれます。
Dan Abramov: それはDID documentにある鍵で署名されていて、その鍵で検証できるんです。
Dan Abramov: もう一つ面白いのは、ネットワークをどうやってスケールさせるかってことですね。
Dan Abramov: 各ユーザーごとにホスティングがあるイメージです。
Dan Abramov: もちろん、多くのユーザーが同じホスティングを使うことも多いです。
Dan Abramov: ホスティングは10万人規模から、1人だけのホスティングまで幅広く対応できます。どちらもOKです。
Dan Abramov: データはそこに保存されているんです。
Dan Abramov: そして、そのデータをすべてのアプリに流す必要がありますよね。
Dan Abramov: でもアプリ側からすると、それはちょっと面倒で…
Dan Abramov: 毎回全部のホスティングにアクセスして何が起きたか調べるのはやりたくないですよね。
Dan Abramov: だからアプリはキャッシュを持って、WebSocketでサブスクライブするんです。
Dan Abramov: でも、さらにスケールさせるにはどうするかって問題が出てきます。
Dan Abramov: 共有インフラが欲しくなりますよね。
Dan Abramov: 共有キャッシュや、共有の再送信機能が必要になります。
Dan Abramov: 理想的には、WebSocketでネットワーク上のすべての出来事、もしくは自分のアプリに関係あるcollectionタイプなどのサブセットを購読できるイベントバスがあるべきなんだ。
Dan Abramov: 彼らが賢いのは、こういう再送信ノードを自分で作れるようにしたことだよ。
Dan Abramov: これがRelayと呼ばれている。
Dan Abramov: BlueskyもRelayを運用しているし、コミュニティ運営のRelayもいくつかあって、WebSocket経由でネットワーク上のすべてのイベントを購読できるんだ。
Dan Abramov: そこで流れるのはコミットのストリームだよ。
Dan Abramov: コミットやID変更などのイベントが流れてくるストリームなんだ。
Dan Abramov: しかも、そのストリームは証明付きで送信される。
Dan Abramov: ストリームには署名済みのコミットが含まれている。
Dan Abramov: つまり、各コミットには署名が付いているんだ。
Dan Abramov: 実際、再送信ノード自体を信頼する必要はない。
Dan Abramov: これも大きなアイデアのひとつだね。
Dan Abramov: 暗号技術が組み込まれているから、ノード自体を信頼しなくていいんだ。
Dan Abramov: コミュニティで再送信ノードや中継ノードを作っても、途中で内容が改ざんされる心配がない。
Dan Abramov: これがAuthenticatedの部分なんだよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、僕なりにまとめてみるね。
シュタイナー・テオ: Personal Data Serverの分布がかなり独特なんだよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 何百万人もユーザーがいるPDSもあれば、家の地下室でホストしてる人もいる。たぶんBlueskyのPDSが前者だよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして、すべてのアプリが全PDSを毎回知ってアクセスし続けるのは現実的じゃないから、Relayサービスがあるってことだよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: たぶん、どこかに超ハイスペックなサーバーがあって、全PDSを把握して全部に購読してるイメージかな。
シュタイナー・テオ: それって、巨大なApache Kafkaみたいなもので、イベントをウェブに流してる感じだね。
Dan Abramov: うん。
Dan Abramov: そんなに高スペックじゃなくても大丈夫だと思う。
Dan Abramov: はっきりとは分からないけど、コスト的には今のトラフィックなら月30ドルくらいで運用できるんじゃないかな。
Dan Abramov: でも、ネットワーク上のPDSを把握する必要があって、それがちょっとややこしいんだよね。どうやって知るのかっていう。
Dan Abramov: 方法はいくつかあるよ。
Dan Abramov: ひとつは、PDSを列挙すること。
Dan Abramov: 既存のRelayには、知っているPDSを列挙できるエンドポイントがあると思う。
Dan Abramov: それでブートストラップできるんだ。
Dan Abramov: PDS側からクロールをリクエストすることもできる。
Dan Abramov: 新しいPDSを立ち上げたら、既知のRelayにpingを送って登録してもらうこともできる。
Dan Abramov: あとはリンク経由で発見することもできる。
Dan Abramov: まだ見たことのないPDSへのリンクを見つけて、それが新しいPDSだったら、クロールするかどうか決められる。
Dan Abramov: だから、そのやり方はRelay次第なんだ。
Dan Abramov: それに、アーカイブを提供するか、単にリトランスミットだけしてアーカイブを持たないかも選べる。アーカイブを維持するのは結構コストがかかるからね…
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、ATProtoで何か作りたい場合、共有データレイヤーがあって、すでにユーザーがたくさんいるアプリがそのデータレイヤーを埋めてるってことだよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そのユーザーたちがアプリを使って、自分のレコードでデータレイヤーを埋めていく。
シュタイナー・テオ: それを活用したいなら、Relayのひとつを使ってデータをダウンロードして、自分のデータベースに入れる感じかな。
シュタイナー・テオ: そういう仕組み？
シュタイナー・テオ: その上でクエリやアプリのロジックを動かすってこと？
Dan Abramov: そう。
Dan Abramov: だから、実際にどうやるかはアプリがどのデータを扱いたいかによると思う。
Dan Abramov: もし自分のデータだけ気にするなら――新しいレコードタイプを作って、それだけを表示するアプリなら――バックフィルは不要だよ。そもそも存在しないから。
Dan Abramov: だから、Relayに接続してリッスンを始めて、アプリが必要なものだけフィルタすれば、レコードが作られ始めた時点で全部取得できる。
Dan Abramov: 以前に存在していたものを取得する必要は実際にはないんだ。
Dan Abramov: これが一番簡単なやり方だね。
Dan Abramov: あとはこの接続を維持して、ユーザーの状況を追いかけていけばいい。
Dan Abramov: 既存データを扱いたい場合は、バックフィルが必要になる。
Dan Abramov: 方法は大きく2つある。
Dan Abramov: 今話しているのは、自分のデータベースにデータを入れたい場合。もちろん何らかの方法で取得しないといけない。
Dan Abramov: そこで問題になるのは、それが大きなアプリか小さなアプリかってこと。
Dan Abramov: 例えばTangledみたいなものなら、Tangledユーザー全員のレコードを全部バックフィルしても、そんなに時間はかからないと思う。
Dan Abramov: 多分5万件くらいかな。正確な数は知らないけど、それほど多くはない。
Dan Abramov: あるいはTeal FMとか。
Dan Abramov: まあ、Teal FMはscrobbleがあるからレコード数は多いかも。今は多分数百万件あるね。
Dan Abramov: でも基本的には、全部の…
Dan Abramov: 多分RelayにこのためのAPIがあると思うけど、特定のタイプのcollectionを持っているユーザーやIDを探す方法がある。
Dan Abramov: だから、特定アプリのユーザーを特定して、そのデータだけ取得できる。
Dan Abramov: こういうことをやるツールもあるよ。
Dan Abramov: TAPっていうバックフィル用のツールがある。
Dan Abramov: どのcollectionを探すか指定すると、それを全部同期して、新しいイベントもリッスンしてくれる。
Dan Abramov: でも、別のアプローチもあるんだ。
Dan Abramov: 特にBlueskyを使いたい場合、全てのBluesky投稿をテラバイト単位でダウンロードしたくはないよね。
Dan Abramov: でも、Blueskyの上に何かアプリを作りたいかもしれない。
Dan Abramov: もちろん、BlueskyのAPIを使うこともできる。
Dan Abramov: それが従来のやり方だけど、ちょっとATProtoらしくない気がするんだよね。
Dan Abramov: 他人のアプリ固有の仕組みに依存することになるから。
Dan Abramov: でも、Constellationっていうツールがあるんだ。
Dan Abramov: これはコミュニティ運営だよ。
Dan Abramov: コミュニティが運営しているサーバーで、全てのレコードをインデックスして、バックリンク用のAPIも提供している。
Dan Abramov: だから、例えば「この投稿にリンクしている全てのレコードを教えて」みたいなことができる。
Dan Abramov: つまり、その投稿の全てのいいねや、ある人の全フォロワー、全引用も取得できるってこと。
Dan Abramov: これは、いわゆるプライマリキー・外部キーのクエリみたいな感じだね。
Dan Abramov: 「このJSONにリンクしているものは何？」って聞くイメージ。
Dan Abramov: 実際これを使えば、バックエンドなしでも動くアプリが作れる。ユーザー固有の情報が欲しいときはそのユーザーのホスティングにアクセスして、もう一段階広げたいときはConstellationを使ってリンクしているもの全部を見る、みたいな感じ。
Dan Abramov: 効率はあまり良くないけど、バックエンド自体が不要になる。
シュタイナー・テオ: そうだね。
シュタイナー・テオ: こうやって話を聞けば聞くほど、最初はAT Protocolってすごく複雑だと思ってたんだ。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも今は、なぜ複雑である必要があるのか分かってきた。スタックを一気にまとめてくれるからなんだね。
シュタイナー・テオ: うちのアプリが必要とするものがどんどん減っていく。
シュタイナー・テオ: データレイヤーも必ずしも必要じゃなくて、ユーザーごとに自分のデータレイヤーがあるし、既存のRelayとかを使って全部集約できるんだ。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ認証レイヤーはいらないってことですよね。ユーザーは…これってアトモスフィアアカウントって呼ばれてますか？
Dan Abramov: そうだね。
Dan Abramov: ちょっと面白いのは、OAuthを使ってるんだよね。
Dan Abramov: OAuthでログインするけど、OAuthプロバイダーが実は自分のPDSなんだ。
Dan Abramov: だから、ある意味Googleアカウントにログインするみたいな感じだけど、自分自身がGoogleみたいなものなんだよ。
Dan Abramov: 自分のホスティングなんだ。
Dan Abramov: だから、もしeurosky.socialに切り替えたら、他のアプリで「atmosphereでログイン」を押すと、今度はeurosky.socialのログインページが表示される。そこが自分のホスティング先だからね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そう、ドメインはeurosky.socialで、そこでログインするんだよね。
Dan Abramov: そうそう。
シュタイナー・テオ: めっちゃ面白いね。
Dan Abramov: だよね。
Dan Abramov: つまり、アイデンティティとデータを持ち上げてる感じ。
Dan Abramov: 僕はこれをウェブの「人中心のデータレイヤー」だと思ってる。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、それって独自の複雑さも生みますよね？
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えば、Instagramの競合アプリを作るとしましょう。
シュタイナー・テオ: そのアプリを作ってて、動作が遅いからデバッグやパフォーマンス改善をしたいとします。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、その問題は自分のプロダクト外にあるかもしれない。
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えば、ユーザーのPDSがすごく遅かったり、ラグがあったりする場合もある。
シュタイナー・テオ: あるいは、Relayがデータ集約で苦戦してる場合もある。
シュタイナー・テオ: そういう時、みんなどうやって対処してるんですか？
Dan Abramov: うん。
Dan Abramov: ホスティング自体については、そのアイデアは結構強いと思う。
Dan Abramov: いいアプリを作りたいなら、ホスティングに頼りすぎない方がいい。データは受信時に集約するからね。
Dan Abramov: だからホスティングはイベントを発行するだけ。
Dan Abramov: ホスティングに一気に千件もリクエスト送るのはやめた方がいい。
Dan Abramov: すべては自分のデータベースやキャッシュから配信すればいい。
Dan Abramov: だからホスティングがちょっと不安定でも、必要なイベントさえ発行してくれれば問題ない。
Dan Abramov: それは大きな問題じゃない。
Dan Abramov: ただのJSONを返すサーバーだから、そんなに重くなるはずがない。
Dan Abramov: もちろん、Blueskyユーザーの場合、Bluesky側でスケーリングの問題が起きたらアプリにも影響する。
Dan Abramov: 一部のイベントが届きにくくなることもある。
Dan Abramov: Relay自体が不安定になることもある。
Dan Abramov: これはもう、そういうものだと思って使うしかない。
Dan Abramov: 君のアプリはよりウェブっぽいから、トラブルの可能性も増える。
Dan Abramov: Relay自体も、Blueskyが運用しているものに依存していれば、基本的には問題なく動いている。
Dan Abramov: たまにトラブルはあるけど、ほとんどは大丈夫。
Dan Abramov: 信用できないなら自分でRelayを立てればいいし、それで上流の問題から完全に切り離せる。
Dan Abramov: 実際、他のアプリが自前のRelayやコミュニティRelayを使っていて、Blueskyアプリが落ちている時でも動いていたことがあった。
Dan Abramov: 時間が経てば……
Dan Abramov: 今はまだアーリーアダプターの段階で、ウェブプロダクトの新しいやり方を信じて運用している感じだね。
Dan Abramov: 90年代のオープンソースみたいなものだと思ってる。
Dan Abramov: 当時は「そんなの無理だ」とか、Microsoftが『オープンソースは癌だ』なんて言ってたけど、10年後にはMicrosoft自身がオープンソースで動いてるんだよね。
Dan Abramov: 今はまさに『そんなの無理だ』って言われる段階だと思う。
Dan Abramov: これはアーリーアダプターの苦労だよ。
Dan Abramov: でも標準化されてるから、あるアプリに役立つものは他のアプリにも役立つ。同じ言語でやりとりできるからね。
Dan Abramov: インフラやライブラリ、ツールも共有できるし、いろんなことができる。
Dan Abramov: そういうインフラが成長して再利用しやすくなれば、ネットワーク全体がもっと強くなるはず。
Dan Abramov: Relayの選択肢も増えていくよ。
Dan Abramov: バックフィルも簡単になる。
Dan Abramov: データを失っても復元できるように、アーカイブも用意されるだろうね。
Dan Abramov: そういう流れが今後もっと増えていくと思う。
シュタイナー・テオ: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 実は今、持続可能性について面白い問題を思いつきました。
シュタイナー・テオ: Blueskyがアプリ層とPDS層の両方を持っているって話がありましたよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: Blueskyならマネタイズの道筋がはっきり見えます。
シュタイナー・テオ: アプリ層があるので、そこから収益化するのは簡単そうです。
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えば広告表示やプレミアムアカウントとか。
シュタイナー・テオ: でもアプリ層を持たないPDSもあって、そういうところは通信やホスティングのコストを一番負担してると思うんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: アプリ側からPDSに還元したり、コスト構造の負担を分散する方法ってあるんでしょうか？
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
Dan Abramov: ちょっと分からないですね。
Dan Abramov: アプリを運用する方が、ホスティングよりも何倍もコストがかかると思います。
Dan Abramov: 100%確信はないですが、まずアプリはユーザーにサービスを提供します。
Dan Abramov: もし毎日100万人のユーザーがいれば、その負荷はアプリにかかります。
Dan Abramov: ホスティングはアプリにサービスを提供します。
Dan Abramov: だから、実際にはすでにかなり分散されています。
Dan Abramov: 特にホストが複数ある場合はそうですね。
Dan Abramov: セルフホストの場合は、自分のデータだけを提供することになります。
Dan Abramov: Mastodonみたいに、投稿がバズると全インスタンスが自分のインスタンスにアクセスしてくるのとは違います。
Dan Abramov: ここでは、アプリが守ってくれるので、そこまで気にしなくていいです。
Dan Abramov: もう一つは、ホスティング自体がまだ新しい概念だと思います。
Dan Abramov: 普通はウェブサイトや会社を持っている場合にホスティングを使いますよね。
Dan Abramov: でも、ネットの利用体験の一部として、Googleアカウントでログインする場合も、それがGoogleとの関係性みたいなものです。
Dan Abramov: この仕組みをもっと広げて、移行可能にできるというのがアイデアです。
Dan Abramov: これは結構新しい発想だと思います。
Dan Abramov: すべてのソーシャルデータが入ったDropboxみたいなものです。
Dan Abramov: それも新しいアイデアですね。
Dan Abramov: 今の時点では、一般ユーザーにはまだ認識されていないと思います。
Dan Abramov: 5年後、もしくは10年後には認識されるかもしれません。
Dan Abramov: でも、ホスティングはサービスも提供できます。
Dan Abramov: 安全なバックアップならお金払ってもいいですね。
Dan Abramov: ホスティングプロバイダーには、何も考えずに定期的に全データをバックアップしてほしいです。
Dan Abramov: それが一つのポイントかもしれません。
Dan Abramov: 他の人は、動画とかのためにもっとストレージが欲しいかもしれませんね。
Dan Abramov: でも基本的には、アプリ側の方がコストが高いと思います。
Dan Abramov: CDNや動画のトランスコーディング、大量の動画配信とか、そういうのはJSON配信よりずっと高コストです。
Dan Abramov: 実際、コストの多くはそこにかかってると思います。
シュタイナー・テオ: つまり、安定したアプリを動かすには、PDSをアプリ層から切り離したいってことですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そしてPDSを切り離すことで、PDSの負荷がアプリ層に移るわけですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: ある意味、自己制御的な仕組みですね。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
Dan Abramov: やっぱり信頼性が大事ですから。
Dan Abramov: PDSの調子が悪くても、それがアプリに影響しないようにしたいです。
Dan Abramov: プロダクトがある程度複雑になると、結局データベースが必要になります。
Dan Abramov: もしくはコミュニティキャッシュを使うこともできますが、それも結局守ってくれてますよね。
Dan Abramov: Constellationを使えば、そこにもキャッシュがあるのでホスティングの負荷も減ります。Constellationはインデックスしたもの全部キャッシュしてますから。
シュタイナー・テオ: 面白いですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: じゃあ、AT Protocolで今まだ足りてないものって何だと思いますか？
シュタイナー・テオ: まだ実装されてないものはありますか？
Dan Abramov: ありますね。
Dan Abramov: 開発者体験や、正しいやり方についてはまだまだ粗削りな部分が多いですね。
Dan Abramov: みんなまだ試行錯誤している段階です。
Dan Abramov: でも今チームが大きく取り組んでいるのは、パーミッション付きデータの対応ですね。
Dan Abramov: 現時点では、ATProtoは完全にパブリックデータにフォーカスしていて、それは正しい選択だったと思います。
Dan Abramov: 最初からプライベートデータを扱うと、スケールがかなり小さくなりますから。
Dan Abramov: そこからパブリックにスケールできるかは分からないですし。
Dan Abramov: 一方で、パブリックにスケールする場合は、集約とか色々なことを効率的に考えないといけません。
Dan Abramov: その上で、パーミッション付きデータにスケールダウンすることもできます。
Dan Abramov: だから今は、プロトコルを拡張したり、もしくは兄弟プロトコルを作ったりして、パブリック再配信を想定しないデータにも対応しようとしています。
Dan Abramov: 例えばグループ機能とかですね。
Dan Abramov: メッセージングは別で、そっちはエンドツーエンド暗号化が必要なので、全く別の話になります。
Dan Abramov: アイデンティティレイヤーの一部は使えるかもしれませんが、それはまた別の課題です。
Dan Abramov: 一方で、メンバーシップで制限されているものは完全なプライベートではなく、アクセス権を持つアプリは表示のために見る必要があります。
Dan Abramov: なので、今はパーミッション付きデータのプロトコル拡張に取り組んでいます。
Dan Abramov: 現状、プライベートやグループ限定のデータが欲しい場合は、自分のデータベースで管理できます。
Dan Abramov: それでも全然問題ないです。
Dan Abramov: ATProtoは、必要な部分だけ取り入れられるという意味で実用的なんですよ。
Dan Abramov: アイデンティティレイヤーだけ使って、他は全部自分のデータベースにしてもOKです。
Dan Abramov: 理想的には、もう少しATProto的な運用に寄せていきたいところですけどね。
Dan Abramov: でもそうすると、グループ単位のデータやユーザー設定など、どこに置くかという壁にぶつかります。
Dan Abramov: ちょっと裏技っぽいけど、一部はBlueskyの設定に保存できるみたいです。
Dan Abramov: でも、プライベートや保護されたデータ用のちゃんとしたAPIは今のところないですね。
Dan Abramov: そこを今まさに開発中なんです。
Dan Abramov: それが一番大きな課題だと思います。
Dan Abramov: 現状、それをプロトコルレベルで実現する方法はありません。
シュタイナー・テオ: Reactコアメンバーがいるポッドキャストで言うのはちょっとアレかもしれませんが、僕はSvelteの大ファンなんです。
シュタイナー・テオ: ATProto界隈では、Svelteで作られてるアプリが結構多い印象ですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 誰か、もしくは何人かで、ATProtoベースのDiscordクローンを作ろうとしてる人たちもいます。
シュタイナー・テオ: たしかRoomy Chatとかいう名前だったと思います。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。はい。
シュタイナー・テオ: でも、まだパーミッション付きデータがないので、プライベートサーバーの実装で詰まってるみたいです。
シュタイナー・テオ: パーミッション付きデータがあれば、アクセス制御の裏でデータを作れるので、その問題も解決できそうですよね。
Dan Abramov: たぶん、そうですね。
Dan Abramov: そう思います。
Dan Abramov: チャットみたいなものは、ちょっと性質が違ってて、どちらかというと一時的なものなんですよね。
Dan Abramov: Discordみたいな場合は残しておきたいかもしれませんが、すべてのチャットメッセージをrecordにする必要があるかは分からないです。
Dan Abramov: それが理にかなってるかどうかは分かりません。
Dan Abramov: でも、パーミッション付きデータがあれば確実に助かりますね。
Dan Abramov: Svelteはその界隈ですごく人気ですよね。
Dan Abramov: なんでなのかは正直分からないです。
Dan Abramov: たぶん、そのエトスに合ってるんだと思う。
Dan Abramov: なんかウェブっぽいよね。
Dan Abramov: 軽くて新しいものっていうイメージがある。
Dan Abramov: Reactは、こういう人たちにとってはJavaみたいな存在だし。
Dan Abramov: それはそれでいいんだけどね。
Dan Abramov: まあ、受け入れるよ。
Dan Abramov: うまくいけば何でもいい。
シュタイナー・テオ: Svelteのアーリーアダプターが多いのと、ATProto自体もまだ新しいからかもしれないね。
Dan Abramov: かもね。うん。
Dan Abramov: でも、結構見た目の雰囲気が大きいと思う。
Dan Abramov: ウェブっぽさがあるし、ATProtoもすごくウェブ的だよね。
Dan Abramov: だから、そこがマッチしてるんだと思う。
シュタイナー・テオ: いやー、今回かなり幅広く話せたね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 他に言い残したことある？
シュタイナー・テオ: まだ触れてない話題とかある？
Dan Abramov: どうだろうね。
Dan Abramov: もっと多くの人に、実際にBlueskyを使ってみてほしい。普段Twitterに投稿してるような内容を、Blueskyでも投稿してみてほしいな。
Dan Abramov: もう一つおすすめしたいのは……
Dan Abramov: デフォルトのフィードはたしかDiscoverって名前だけど、正直あまり良くないと思う。
Dan Abramov: For Youっていうカスタムフィードがあって、Twitterの「For You」フィードみたいな感じで、すごく良いよ。
Dan Abramov: Blueskyアプリのフィードタブで検索すれば見つかりますよ。
Dan Abramov: これは本当におすすめです。
Dan Abramov: 自分の「いいね」や、同じものに「いいね」した人たちの傾向から学習してくれます。
Dan Abramov: 正直、昔のTwitterのアルゴリズムと同じくらい良いと感じてます。
Dan Abramov: いつもそのフィードを使ってます。
Dan Abramov: 面白いのは、このフィードが実際に誰かの自宅ゲーミングPCで動いてることですね。
Dan Abramov: そもそもフィードって何かというと…
Dan Abramov: 単に投稿のAT URI配列を返すHTTPサービスなんですよ。
Dan Abramov: ネットワーク内のすべてはAT URIで識別されてるので、どこでホストされてても関係ないんです。
Dan Abramov: みんな同じものを扱ってるから、こういうサービスが作れるんですよね。
Dan Abramov: このFor YouフィードはAT URIの配列を返してページネーションして、BlueskyアプリがそのフィードにアクセスしてURIを取得し、データベースから実際の投稿に変換して表示します。
Dan Abramov: Blueskyでユーザーランドのフィードが作れるのは本当にクールです。
Dan Abramov: これが一番いいフィードだと思います。
Dan Abramov: 特にBlueskyに人を誘いたいなら、「For Youフィードを入れてみて」って言えばいいですよ。単純にこっちの方が優れてますから。
シュタイナー・テオ: 僕もFor You使ってます。
シュタイナー・テオ: しかもすごく面白いのが、たまにフィードのホストしてる人が1時間くらい落ちてて、戻ってきたら「ごめん、PCアップグレードしてた。RAM増設したよ」みたいな投稿があるんですよ。
Dan Abramov: そうそう。
シュタイナー・テオ: すごくハックっぽくてクールですよね。
Dan Abramov: うん。
シュタイナー・テオ: なるほど。
シュタイナー・テオ: 今日はこのへんで終わりにしましょうか。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: ATProtoについて話してくれて本当にありがとうございました。
シュタイナー・テオ: ご自身では言いにくいかもしれませんが、ATProtoを学ぶ一番いい方法はあなたのブログだと思います。
シュタイナー・テオ: ATProtoの仕組みをいろんな切り口で解説した連載記事がありますよね。
シュタイナー・テオ: ファイルシステムの例えが特に分かりやすかったです。
シュタイナー・テオ: それからBlueskyで、気になる人たちをどんどんフォローしてみてください。
シュタイナー・テオ: 個人的なおすすめはStarter Packです。
シュタイナー・テオ: ワンクリックで自分の興味分野の人たちをまとめてフォローできます。
Dan Abramov: そうですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: 例えば、React Starter PackやWeb Dev Starter Packに入ってそうですよね。
Dan Abramov: たぶん、もしあれば入ってると思います。
Dan Abramov: JavaScript用のも確実にありますよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: 僕はSvelte Starter Packに入ってて、たくさんいいねももらえてすごく嬉しかったです。
Dan Abramov: なるほど。
シュタイナー・テオ: 実はこの番組もBlueskyに載せてます——もしまだなら、この投稿のあと必ず載せます。
シュタイナー・テオ: 普通のHTTPウェブでもいつでもチェックできますよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: ドメインは「uit-inside.linecorp.com」です。
シュタイナー・テオ: まだフォローしていない方は、ぜひDanもフォローしてくださいね。
シュタイナー・テオ: そして最後まで聴いてくれて本当にありがとうございました。
シュタイナー・テオ: 他のエピソードも聴きたい方は、ほとんど日本語ですが、英語回も3〜4本ありますよ。
シュタイナー・テオ: ぜひ探してみてください。
シュタイナー・テオ: もしくは日本語を勉強してみるのもアリですね。
シュタイナー・テオ: あるいは翻訳ツールを使ってもいいかも。
シュタイナー・テオ: 今日は来てくれて本当にありがとうございました。
シュタイナー・テオ: それでは、バイバイ。
Dan Abramov: ありがとうございました。